[Music]
have you ever seen a sunrise like this
before one so bright that you couldn't
leave your house without sunglasses and
you'd want to avoid Sun Tanning at all
costs well of course you have it because
that's not our son it's the largest star
that we've ever discovered uy scuti and
if it were to replace our Sun it would
change a lot more than just the amount
of sunscreen you'd have to put on how
long would it take for our planet to
orbit this massive star what would that
do to our seasons would we even survive
a single orbit this is what if and
here's what would happen if earth
orbited uy scuti to say that uy scuti is
huge would be an understatement it's one
of the largest things that the human
race has ever discovered to put it in
perspective it's about 1,700 times
larger than our Sun if you were to fly a
Boeing 777 airplane around uy scuti it
would take over 1,200 years to make the
trip so would a star this gigantic even
fit into the center of our solar system
[Music]
before we can answer that we need to get
to know you why scooty a little better
discovered by German astronomers in 1860
UI scooty is located in the Scouten
constellation about 9,500 light-years
from Earth it's a pulsating star that
swells and shrinks periodically usually
shining about four hundred thousand
times brighter than our Sun if UI scooty
took our Suns placed in the center of
our solar system it would engulf
everything as far out as the orbit of
Saturn that includes all of us here on
earth so maybe it's better to leave that
huge star where it
instead we could just move the earth to
the orbit of uy scuti but we'd have to
be careful how close we place our planet
to this gigantic star to be habitable
we'd have to put our planet in orbit
about one-and-a-half trillion kilometers
away from uy scuti at this distance it
would take about ten thousand years for
earth to complete just one orbit around
the celestial body that would change our
entire concept of life as we know it
each season would last 2,500 years that
means that entire civilizations could
rise and fall without ever seeing more
than one season for most people summer
might be something they've only heard
about through legends in case a
perpetual winter isn't bad enough don't
forget that the orbit around uy scuti
would be located right in the middle of
the Milky Way where cosmic rays and
light from other stars would shine
bright enough to keep our sky blue all
day and night on top of that UI scooty
would be pulsing out extra heavy
radiation about every 740 days and
things would only get worse the longer
we stay there you see uy scuti is a red
giant which means it's a lot closer to
its death than our Sun is about 40 times
closer to be precise when it does die
it's expected to explode with the force
of more than 100 supernovas a supernova
is the explosion of a star and it's the
largest explosion that takes place in
space so the force of 100 stars
exploding would obliterate everything
nearby even if the earth was far enough
away to survive the blast without the
star there would be no heat and no light
and life couldn't survive on earth
without those two things
so once again what if has killed off the
entire human race maybe it's a better
idea to leave earth where it is and
appreciate how lucky we are to orbit our
Sun well until it explodes but that's a
story for another what if
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]